please welcome mike jackson and egypt
sherrod
wow
you guys are stunning in person i thank
you well look who's talking i know
we've decided i'm diane keaton in the
latest hallmark christmas movie
um adorable is it true egypt that you
guys met during like a house flip
that kind of we met before you want to
tell us we had three different incidents
where we met you know it was ordained
short version short first we met the
light was only shining on her i said
that's my wife
but literally drew so when he met me he
actually said that and i thought it was
a line so i was like excuse me
i thought it was online i thought he was
adorable i mean obviously but i don't
like lines like just talk to me
but i miss i missed out so a year later
i was working on a flip house in new
jersey i decided to try and tar a roof
by myself and i fell through
decided i needed some help obviously and
his team showed up
with his ass on his chest
and i said wait a minute i know you and
he's like uh-huh
it was ordained what are you doing here
he's like this is my team this is what i
do and then he looked really sexy in his
tool belt i just couldn't resist like
the whole belt
i was standing there eating french fries
watching him work like
and then you guys fell in love and now
you're making a show together and it's
amazing right it's a blessing it's
you're doing
something you love with the person you
love
something you love with the person you
love well i
love design yes we know um design's my
boyfriend
and i would love to ask you guys some
hot tips advice
sort of you know gut instincts takes
because this is this is my sexy
conversation
okay what is a trend you love though
right now i think
future walls are becoming very trendy
well no because but they're not going
anywhere well but it's like we started
with feature walls uh for those who
followed hdtv what a decade ago it was
just paint a wall right and it was a
feature wall and now we have gotten so
explicit with it and so creative mike
and i will literally pick up you
remember the remnants yes he had
hardwood floor remnants and they're
sitting in the pile and it's like how
can we use these yeah and make this
amazing art on the wall it's a feature
wall okay so that to me is a great
design tip now what is a paint that
everybody should dare to use what's a
color you dare people i love right that
i dare you to use yeah i love you know i
love blues i love moody blue
um what's the one that we just use the
aqua smoke oh there's this color it just
honestly this this color makes me want
to just make love to my husband oh what
what is that color
who makes it
by this color it will send your hormones
raging it's called aqua smoke well okay
so we have a woman who wrote us in for
um a design dilemma and she really wants
your help um would you be willing to
guide her through
um two spaces that she has questions
about that's the dilemma
perfect bring it on roll the tank
hi drew barry marshall my name is simone
and i'm the mother of two amazing but
sloppy children i could really use your
help with our entryway
my kids throw everything and anything in
that space and it makes the house look
junky and cluttered before you even get
in the house i could really use your
help with that space
hi simone hi drew i'm so happy to be
here i'm so happy to be with you you are
so stylish i'm picking up everything you
are putting down all right simone what
is like your number one frustration when
you walk in the door you said it on the
video sloppy first of all coming home
from a full day of work nobody wants to
come into their home or their space and
like boom the crap is right there i need
help because when it comes to decor
organization that's i'm i'm very
i'm not that person all right well egypt
um your solution is genius and budget
friendly tell us okay so get ready for
this it's going to completely blow your
mind
okay when you take a look over here at
this amazing mud room would you be
surprised to know that this is just a
hundred dollar bookshelf
what
yeah baby a bookshelf we completely made
a drop zone out of a bookshelf that you
can buy at a big box store anyone can do
this add some baskets peel and stick
wallpaper in the back
depending on the season or the color
that you're feeling of the week you can
also change out the wallpaper or go
right on top of it and mike like explain
how to do this what do you do
this is the backing which is here now if
you notice this is three bookshelves put
together if you did have this you take
the shelves and you would screw them
together so they would be anchored
safely right now if for some reason the
backing of that particular bookshelf
that you find at a big box store or
maybe a consignment shop doesn't come
off you may want to cut this to size
then peel it and stick it on there i
love an exacto knife too if it does pop
off pop it off
do it right here on the table or a table
stick it on there pop it right back in
and then once that's said and done
grab you some hooks
and place them where you want them to go
any style that fits your style and
you're all done
[Music]
you